we talked about getting a cart and I was
going to get a cart and then I'm
standing there and you know I'm I'm
already on the sideline at that point
the tunnel's right there I just wanted
to get off the field get out of there I
didn't know what was going on with my
ankle and I felt like I could get off
and I was like hey you're good just
don't bring it out I'm going in and then
once I got in there I'm like this is a
pretty long walk you know but I I was
already there and they asked again if I
wanted a cart I'm like no we're going to
make it the whole way there I didn't
know there was cameras in the tunnel you
know so that's kind of they're
everywhere exactly so uh but no it's of
course we have carts and we have
everything we need and I was the one
that that didn't choose to to take one
you know so